well I haven't seen any of these
firsthand I'm assuming that mostly
interrogators and government
interpreters see that but dr. Ali Shah
spoke about being beaten extremes of
heat and cold sleep deprivation for
weeks being made to stand for long
periods of time to the point where he
couldn't stand anymore because his legs
felt like these wet noodles and they
would give and so they would beat him
back into a standing position being
cursed about his nationality religion
his family being called a terrorist
accused of being complicit in 911 and
not being able to stand up for himself
and that happened at Bagram Air Base by
us the US military right before he was
brought to Guantanamo and the 80 year
old man similarly spoke of abuse of he
was being to the point of arm injury and
he ha genus throughout the 8 year olds
paraplegic was reluctant to speak about
his torture and abuse because I found
that when you ask prisoners about the
retort or it's a difficult subject to
speak about because in essence they're
reliving their their shame and the
experiences that they've endured so some
of them